let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
good wednesday afternoon everybody
welcome to episode 11 of the tony
michaels podcast
we have a lot of things
to talk about today
[Music]
you've been watching the news you've
been seeing what's going on
[Music]
so
[Music]
let's talk about it the thing that's on
everybody's mind is
not only uh gun control and gun reform
but to end the filibuster to possibly
get
gun control and gun reform we had a bill
passed out of the house about background
checks it doesn't look like joe manchin
is in favor of that bill which i don't
understand
um the simple act of background checks
the majority of america not only just
liberals those liberal gun-hating
liberals
but we also have uh the most of
you know gun owning
americans want background checks and i i
don't think that's unreasonable
that the background check is that's one
of the easiest box
boxes to check here is the background
check
thing the idea that you can't do a
background check cause you buy a gun i
mean good god
to go get a license in most states to
cut hair
to cut someone's hair you got to do a
[ __ ] background check
come on to go get a [ __ ] job at a
goddamn fast food place you gotta do a
background check
come on we can't do a background check
to buy a [ __ ] weapon give me a break
as this is ridiculous it's getting
ridiculous more and more ridiculous
and then you know rather joe manchin
holds up this process or not
uh we'll find out but that that those
are the things on everybody's mind
cause last week when i was on i had to
talk about a
mass shooting down in atlanta where a
bonehead went into
three massage piles parlors and mowed
down eight people
now this week i have to talk about
another knucklehead
with a semi-automatic rifle running into
a grocery store and killing 10 people
and i'm sure next week i may be talking
about the same god damn thing
every [ __ ] week and it seems like
because this pandemic is
winding down if you want to call it that
where more more people are getting
vaccinated
that now we're getting back to a normal
our normal is mass shootings in this
country
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and we wanted to get back to normal i
don't know
maybe there's some argument for
quarantines
speaking of the vaccine please go get
vaccinated while i'm on that subject
please go get vaccinated it doesn't
matter which one you get if you can get
it go get it
tomorrow i get my first microchip in my
arm
you know that my tracking chip
they're going to put my modern tracking
chip in my arm my first one
and then i go get the upgrade after that
i guess so
i will be i will will be receiving my
very first
uh vaccine shot the moderna tomorrow so
i'll give you some updates on that
maybe i'll do some videos put them on
tic tac i'll tweet out some stuff
you guys can see that i appreciate you
guys hanging out on the podcast with me
uh every week wednesday at three o'clock
uh four o'clock
uh eastern three o'clock central uh
live on youtube you guys are watching me
on youtube and we're live on twitter we
we stream on twitter twitter now too
since i'm over there
uh we stream so the people that uh with
the tweet tweet
can uh can watch us over there i do want
to mention before i get into
uh the subject at hand today which is
these republican stupid [ __ ]
arguments about why gun reform can't
happen because you know
we just can't we just can't have
reasonable gun gun control
in this country which we already have
but we can't do any more about it it's
just not possible
we just we we've never done that before
it's never been proven to work and we
can't do that
so this is that's the subject we're
going to talk about today but before we
get to that
i do want to see if you guys would help
support the podcast we've got some
stickers some [ __ ] stickers
we got [ __ ] hats all that's over at
the tonymichaels.com
anything you purchase on the merch store
or a nice [ __ ] hat you see the
[ __ ] hat there
we'll help out the podcast here so i
really appreciate your support and thank
you so
much i'm gonna get off that subject now
so let's get into
that the the the subject at hand
and that is republicans argument about
why we should not and cannot and it's
a tyrannical thing and oh they're gonna
come take my guns i'm gonna have someone
knock on my door
joe biden's gonna come knock on my door
and take my guns
give me a [ __ ] break bill clinton
didn't take our guns
barack obama didn't take your [ __ ]
guns
joe biden's not gonna take your [ __ ]
guns
it's not in 1994
this country had a 10-year ban on
assault weapons and certain handguns
10 years and no one came and got your
guns
no one nobody
came and got your guns not one
[ __ ] from the government came
knocking on your door when we had the
assault weapons ban
in place from 1994 to 2004 10 years
we've done it in this country and it
worked it [ __ ]
worked now i'm not saying we should do
the exact same bill
other than we should do the exact same
bill
and just make what worked work again i
mean that that
that seems like a good idea but the
reason why
we don't they don't they don't want us
to have
this the opportunity to save people's
lives in this country
from regulating manufacturers selling
certain types of weapons to the public
is because it's profitable that's why
that's what this hole they're gonna take
your guns is
is to get inside of the heads of these
deluded [ __ ] who will believe anything
you [ __ ] tell them
and make them think hey if they're gonna
come get your guns
you better go buy more ammo before they
come take them oh and you better buy
guns too cause they're gonna take those
too you better stock up
wink wink go stock up
we see the same stupid [ __ ] happen
during the pandemic with things
like toilet paper everyone thought oh my
god we're gonna run out of toilet paper
so everyone ran to the [ __ ] grocery
store and the walmart and costco and
sam's
and bought every [ __ ] roll
they had more goddamn toilet paper than
they had [ __ ] meat in their house
as if you weren't gonna be able to wipe
your ass
because of the coronavirus and the only
reason why is because
everyone thought how am i gonna get
toilet paper if there is none
and it was gone
well guess what the gun manufacturers
they're doing the same thing with ammo
and guns you
[ __ ] morons it's the same [ __ ]
that's what the take your guns is that's
all it is
is to convince knuckleheads knuckle
draggers
to go spend more money on ammo they
don't need because they got a whole room
full of it because they done bought
all they could buy last year before it
came off the shelf because joe biden is
going to win he's going to take your
guns
better buy all that ammo this year
barack obama was the was the most
profitable president the gun
manufacturers have
ever seen in their lifetimes
the most profitable
you would think that the gun
manufacturers would want it would one of
trump to win
i don't know it's a hell of a lot easier
it's a hell of a lot easier to sell ammo
it's a hell of a lot easier to sell ammo
when when you can convince your
customers that there will be none
because of a certain politician
hmm well then we get into
some of the congressional hearings and
the senate hearings that we've been
having
on this subject that were scheduled
after
the last week's mass shooting and then
they happened to fall
just the day after we had the mass
shooting this week
because that's that's that's what we do
in this country is have weekly mass
shootings
it's a weekly thing it's the american
way it's american as apple pie
so they you know they go on their
regular list of [ __ ]
that they wanna you know excuse that
they wanna make
for not giving sensible regulations
on certain type of weapons and how to
get those weapons
uh if you should wait to get those
weapons what is sensible and what is not
rather they should be banned or just
simply regulated
nope the arguments are always the
[ __ ] same it's always the same
they never change the script and the
reason why is because they don't need to
change the script
because they got their knuckle draggers
out there all convinced that
someone's gonna take my guns and i'm
gonna go buy my guns because that's all
they want
they don't give a [ __ ] about the
regulations they don't give a [ __ ]
as long as they can sell guns and sell
ammo that's all they care about
they don't care if you keep or get your
guns taken away from you
frankly the gun manufacturers would love
if you got your guns taken away
from you they could sell you more
it would be perfect what an idea
so i did a little walking rant on this
today
and i want to play that and then break
down each one of these stupid [ __ ]
arguments
of why we can't sensibly regulate guns
in this country
on the other side so let's play it and
i'll see you on the
side what are you [ __ ] mental let's
talk
a week here in america and we have
another mass shooting we've already
started through the progression of the
arguments of the republicans of why we
can't regulate semi-automatic rifles
first things first
guns don't kill people people kill
people you know like drunk drivers and
[ __ ] they do know that you have to have
a license to drive right jesus [ __ ]
cricket on the list
you can't take my guns because you can't
take my whiteness you ever heard of
felons
let's work our way on down to the next
one tyrannical government
[ __ ] shit-eating morons have heard of
tanks drones and
nuclear weapons right next it's an
individual right
then why does it say a regulated militia
personal protection who has these type
of [ __ ] enemies
hunting because i gotta use it for
hunting because those whitetail are
heavily armed last but not least we've
reached the stage of mental illness is
the problem [ __ ] boneheads realize
that everyone has a certain degree of
mental illness but not everyone owns
semi-automatic [ __ ] rifles
[ __ ] them
well that's a whole list of them isn't
it i don't think it's all of them
but it's all it's always the main points
that they have
so let's start at the top guns don't
kill people
people kill people and then they trudge
out these arguments about drunk drivers
well
a car doesn't kill someone it's the
person that's driving the car to kill
somebody
i mean they're the one getting drunk you
can't stop showing them getting drunk
yeah you can't stop someone from getting
drunk and getting behind the wheel of a
car
you can't you won't number one
a car is really really [ __ ] heavy
regulated you
dumb [ __ ] i mean they require seat
belts they require certain safety
measures
you have to have certain licensing and
insurance to even sell a car
in most states
to get a loan for a car you have to
provide insurance liability insurance i
mean the list goes on and on and on and
on
just about the car itself but let's talk
about the person because the person is
the one that kills people
not the car well
technically speaking a person to legally
drive in any state in this country
has to have a license they have to have
a license
and they have to prove that they are
capable of having a license
most states that means they have to take
a [ __ ] test
they have to renew their license and a
lot of times not only do you have to
take a test you have to retake test
there's retesting when you re-license
when you renew your license in most
states
there's an eye test there's a signed
test you want to make sure you know
you're not some bonehead that forgot how
to drive
so setting that aside
but the point is is that the licensing
and the insurance and the regulations of
the car
and the regulations of getting a license
yes does that
that's not going to prevent someone from
getting in the car and driving just
because they don't have a license
but generally speaking generally
speaking
if you get pulled over and you don't
have a [ __ ] license
there's gonna be some repercussions
generally speaking if you get pulled
over or you're in an accident you don't
have insurance
there's gonna be repercussions
it's heavily regulated it's heavily
regulated
and yet yet the argument still is oh
well people don't
guns don't kill people people kill
people just like cars just like
cars
so i'll move on to the next argument
because that one's just absolutely
[ __ ]
ridiculous i will say one more thing
about people kill people and guns don't
there is there is a movie called billy
madison you guys know billy madison
and on there there is a t-shirt inside
that movie it's
one of my favorite t-shirts of all time
because i think it's hilarious it says
guns don't kill people i kill people so
i think that's
that's funny so let's move on to the
next argument you can't take my guns
out of my cold dead hands
you can't take my guns well that's all
[ __ ]
we can take your guns we do we take guns
out of people's hands
every [ __ ] day in this country
and there are millions of people in this
country
who can't have guns they're called
felons
they're called felons
and really actually the whole felony gun
law is to prevent
black people from owning guns the whole
point
get them all caught up in a felony and
then they don't own guns but white
people are felons too
and they don't own guns
but here's the thing because mr
john kennedy senator if you want to call
him that
made the argument in a hearing the other
day about about guns and taking guns and
you know if a muslim commits terrorism
foreign or domestic we you don't want us
you don't want us to compare every
muslim to that terrorist do you
what he's saying is is white people
want guns and white people want to keep
their guns
because it's a white thing
and coming from white rule america there
is
a white rule culture around guns
it is a thing it's
a [ __ ] thing white
rule people have a gun
culture and that's what they're worried
about oh
you're gonna take our ability to take
our guns and this plays into the
the whole hunting thing which i'll talk
about later and they conflate hunting
and the right to own guns they totally
mix these two [ __ ] things together i
watched it on my twitter feed today when
i asked the question
would a gun owner would a gun nut if
they had to choose
choose their right to own a
semi-automatic rifle not a gun
a semi-automatic rifle
or the right to vote which one would
they choose i posed that question
which one would a gun nut choose
their right to own a semi-automatic
rifle
not just a gun a semi-automatic rifle
or the right to vote
well i believe in the in the
rural white gun culture
because i lived in it i believe they
would choose
the right to own a semi-automatic
weapon and the reason why because they
see
that as their power to control the
others
in the country others that's how they
view it
in their culture that
is the purpose that's it right there
why do you think john kennedy talks
about muslims and
domestic and terrorists and and and
foreign terrorists
in the same sentence when he's talking
about gun owners
and their rat stone guns
you can't take that away from them
no one's taking your guns
what people are saying is certain types
of guns should be regulated
for the manufacturing and sale of those
types of guns
because we have a gun problem not a
people problem
and we're going to get to the people
problem because they make this stupid
[ __ ] argument too
and and the reason why that's a stupid
[ __ ] argument is because they never
get to the solution
for the argument that they're making
but let's get back let's get back
to this white culture
white gun rule culture
because that is what they're saying
that's what they're saying
that's what they're scared of and they
would much
rather they would much rather have the
power of a gun
to kill people to force their ideas and
their beliefs on someone
with fear than the vote
and that is why we are broken in this
country
that's why that's that's why the
majority of white people in this country
have been [ __ ] brainwashed and and
been deluded
to believe in trumpism
is because they don't understand that
the right to vote
is your way to policy
the amendments and rights in this
country and the freedoms that you have
aren't aren't some sort of [ __ ]
individual object
those freedoms those rights provide your
vehicle to liberty
that's the thing we strive for and the
only way
the only way to liberty is to make sure
to have good policy to make sure that
those rights and those freedoms are
afforded to
everyone
that's the point and they miss the
entire
[ __ ] point
that when you elect people because we we
as
citizens we as citizens do
not make policy we don't
we are not politicians we don't
make policy what we do in a
constitutional
republic representative republic the
democracy which we live in
is we elect a representative to go make
policy for us
it just so happens they're called
politicians i wonder why that is
but because that is the type of
democracy that we live in
we have to rely on them to go make our
policies
and this delusional idea this delusional
idea that the way to make policy in this
country
is to make people afraid
is going to lose because that is not the
system that we win
and that is the stress that we have
that is the stress that we have
in our democracy which is
a constitutional representative republic
that's the type of democracy that we
live in
you get that dumb argument too but we're
not even gonna get into that today
but they don't understand that the
policy
is made by the politicians not with the
fear of a gun
it never ends well when you have the
fear of a weapon
and you try to use the fear of the
weapon to control
everyone and they do this with
everything
they do this with everything it's guns
this week it was mr potato head and dr
seuss last week
everything they do this with everything
the fear-mongering
making you afraid of something like
convincing you of something that isn't
true
because you're afraid you ever been you
ever remember when you were a kid and
you were afraid of the monster under
your bed
until someone told you it wasn't there
here we are here we are
now the next the next [ __ ] argument
tyrannical government we gotta stop our
government from taking our guns
well here's the here's the thing you
[ __ ] boneheads you get to elect your
government too
[ __ ] we lived under four years of uh uh
two years excuse me two years of a
republican president
a republican house a republican senate
you elected them to make your policy you
did
we did they were our government
so why why were you scared then
the same people vote the same people
vote or
could vote every time
and then the simple fact of that the
tyrannical government
when we ask for our independence from
britain
the tyrannical government that they're
talking about
that's that's the tyrannical government
that they're they're talking about
they're not talking about ours they're
talking about other governments
because in the context of when we
started this country
we were fighting another government
forming our own
but besides that point
there's a thing called the united states
military
you know tanks
drones missiles
fighter planes the navy
nuclear weapons
i think that's an easy point to make
your little pea shooters
aren't going to do much good when they
can lay
waste on you from a little room in a
bunker with a drone
you and your oath keeper proud boys
types your little militia
hate to tell you this you're not that
tough
you're not you're not that
tough
yes there will be casualties because
you're boneheads
but you're not that tough
so let's just move on from that argument
because
who in the hell actually who in the hell
actually thinks that they have an
arsenal at their home
in their little gun cabinet that they
think they're going to sling them on
their back and go take over the united
states government
and take on the united states military
what
oh this person i'd like to meet wow
the next one is uh individual right well
we can we can just
just this issue of individual right
and the reason why we have the situation
that we're in is because they fought for
this stupid thing
to be called an individual right and
that's the problem that we have it is
not an individual right
it doesn't say that it says regulated
militia
doesn't say an unregulated person who to
have guns
in their house so they can pew pew pew
everybody it does not say that it says
regular well regulated militia and when
you talk to these gun nuts and they
start
they start spewing the second amendment
you know they they know word for word
the first
part they know a word for but when it
gets to the real
well regulated militia part and they
they you lost them
they really need to go you know dig out
the old dictionary knock the dust off of
it
and look up the word regulated and
militia
that'll help you with your individual
right
argument now the next one is the one
that they always trudge out
they always trudge out and this is again
this is more part of the fear
thing this is the [ __ ] fear factor
this is the thing that they
really want to really want to dig deep
in your mind
and this is where the gun manufacturers
get into it
is personal protection well i have it to
protect my family
that's why i have them in case some
person breaks into my house and i have
to put
56 bullets in them because they're gonna
try to steal my tv
okay number one your your stealing your
tv is not your personal protection
that's your personal property
and i don't even have to explain why
the death sentence does or the death
sentence is not constituted for stealing
a tv
number one number two what kind of
enemies that do you have
that you need an entire arsenal that you
think is going to overthrow the united
states government which it won't
but you think it's going to what type of
interviews do you have that you need to
protect yourself from
i mean you got a lot more problems than
what kind of guns you could own
apparently
so the personal protection is the one
they always want to dredge out
well you know if you got a gun in the
house
rather it's a a semi-automatic rifle
or a deer rifle or hunting rifle which
is the thing we're gonna get into next
i think that would be enough like a
shotgun
i don't know if anyone's heard a shotgun
clack but the clack of a shotgun
is very very very very very significant
in making sure that someone uh behaves
the way that they you want them to
behave
so this idea that you need
semi-automatic rifles
semi-automatic guns to protect yourself
and your family
is is a little is a little ridiculous
it's a little ridiculous because for 10
years in this country
you couldn't go just buy semi-automatic
guns certain rifles certain weapons in
this country and everyone protected
their family just fine
okay and then we get to the hunting
thing oh jesus christ
because this is this is again this is
part of white rule america's culture
is the hunting it's the hunting
and this is where they get afraid that
someone's going to come to their house
and take their guns because by god my
guns
my guns my guns aren't aren't
semi-automatic but i happen to hunt deer
and hut
turkey of course you do
they're not they're not talking about
those guns number number one they're not
we're not talking about those guns we're
not
they're not that's that's not that's not
what
stalwarts are saying what they're
talking about is guns that are designed
to
kill people not not hunt animals
okay kinds of guns that are designed to
hunt animals
no one's wanting to ban those guns
and the other argument that uh oh well
this gun
this gun here this semi semi-iron man
gun it really helps me kill deer better
it helps me be a better deer hunter how
shitty of a deer hunter are you
that you need a semi-automatic weapon to
go hunt deer
are you that shitty of a of a [ __ ] of
a hunter
and if you are maybe go practice maybe
go practice
practicing you know shooting ranges to
practice at
maybe you should go practice with your
weapon your hunting weapon
the other boneheaded thing about this is
i kind of put these together in my video
is uh that white-tailed deer
you know they're heavily armed so we got
to protect ourselves from whitetail deer
come on really i mean people go hunting
with bows
bow and arrows people go hunting with
bow and arrows
you have to have a semi-automatic weapon
to go hunting
you're worthless okay it might be fun to
mow down a deer with a semi-automatic
weapon
but it's not necessary it's not
necessary
now the next one is the one that we're
gonna hear for the next
week and a half and they're gonna
continue and continue because they
always
work their way down to this one because
all the other arguments
all the other arguments are complete
[ __ ] garbage you tear them apart in
an instant
uh once you use logical and critical
thinking you realize that they're the
stupidest [ __ ] arguments
that there could be they get to the
mental health argument
because it's probably the most
compelling argument
is that a mentally ill person shouldn't
own a [ __ ] firearm
that can mow down [ __ ] dozens of
people
it's a compelling argument
the problem is is they miss on the
mentally ill
argument they miss and the reason why
they miss
is because they blame it on mental
illness but they don't want to do
anything about it
because let's be frank and i've said
this in my video i tweeted it out
most people have some sort
of mental illness but not everyone owns
semi-automatic weapons not
everybody owns semi-automatic weapons
but
most people i would say that there's a
really high percentage
i'm talking in the 90s folks
of people having mental illness now
what i mean by that it's not that you're
a crazy psychotic person
but people get their brain sick
your brain gets sick sometimes it's a
temporary thing
sometimes it's a permanent thing
sometimes it takes a little while to get
yourself back in order
sometimes it takes a lot to get yourself
back in order
and the likely that you may never get
yourself back in order
but when they make the mentally ill
argument they fall
short because they never they never say
okay it's a mental illness problem we
can keep the semi-automatic rifles and
weapons
but let's give everyone mental health
care and
access to mental health care well they
just get that socialist
what are you doing that's so you can't
you can't give people
you can't give people you can't give
people access to healthcare
what are you crazy what do you think
this is what do you think this
is a socialist country
it'll kill us our government will topple
that tyrannical government that we're
trying to protect ourselves from with
the firearms that we're trying not to
ban
it'll topple if we have universal health
care and provide mental health care to
mentally ill people
guys mental illness is not a [ __ ]
visual thing
you can't see mental illness everyone
has mental illness everyone
at some point in your life you've
suffered from mental illness whether you
realize it or not
you have your [ __ ] brain
gets sick
so that's the most compelling argument
that they have but they fall short of
anything
actually being done about it it's just a
[ __ ] gaslighting smoke screen is all
it is
because it is a compelling argument to
give people mental health care
that is a really good [ __ ] that that
is a thing we need to do
in this country and nothing has been
more clear
than the past four years that we need
mental health care
right the [ __ ] now right now we need
need mental health care in this country
and it needs to be universal
we have people out there that believe
that democrats are some part of
some sort of a blood-sucking cabal and
that donald trump is secretly the
president joe biden's on a movie
set and donald trump's going to take
over on march 20th and march 4th
april 29th september 82nd
these people need mental health care
quick
fast and in a hurry
so yes there's a compelling argument for
mental health care
but it has a hell of a lot more to do
with this country as a whole than guns
[Music]
so if mental illness is really your
argument and that's where you
[ __ ] always land
which they always land there they always
land on mental illness and the reason
why they land on mental illness
is because liberals and progresses go
yeah we need mental health yeah it is
yeah you know we don't want mentally ill
people to have guns
because we shouldn't let mentally ill
people have guns
we shouldn't and i'm not promoting any
one certain policy folks
because i don't make policy
we don't make policy politicians make
policy
we elect politicians to go make our
policy for us
that's why we have to vote for the right
politicians to make our policy
we need to stop we need to stop voting
for
[ __ ] social media [ __ ]
for politicians and start electing
people
who know policy
who want to institute policy
rather it be on mental illness which you
[ __ ] today are claiming that's
the most important thing in the country
right now
is mental illness last week it was dr
seuss
and mr potato head cancer culture
clearly you have mental illness
and this week it's not gun control it's
mental illness because there's no such
thing as gun control the only thing
that's
controlled is the mental illness that's
the only thing we need to control
is mental illness in this country the
[ __ ]
out of here you know what you can do
you know what you can do in this country
it's a really cool thing
it's a really cool thing in this country
when we have rights and freedoms and
liberty
you can do a really cool thing you can
set policy to regulate
weapons of mass destruction
you can you can set policy to regulate
personal weapons like semi-automatic
rifles
and some semi-automatic handguns and
other weapons that you could just go buy
at a store
you can set policy to regulate cars like
you [ __ ]
argue you know what you can also do at
the same exact [ __ ] time
the same exact time the same exact time
that you're doing all that
you can set policy to help people get
mental health care
because there is no clearer example of
mental health care in this country
than people who are running around
yelling and screaming about someone
taking their [ __ ] guns
you have a [ __ ] sickness in your
goddamn brain
you are sick you are sick you may not
realize it
you may not know it but you are sick
there is a delusion about you and you
need to get it fixed
either sit and think about it for a
while do some [ __ ] yoga
you know meditate on it go see a
therapist
you were sick no one
no one is talking in the government
about taking your guns away
not [ __ ] one of them not a goddamn
one of them
we had a [ __ ] law in this country for
10 years
10 years from 1994 to 2004
that banned these weapons
we've already done it we've done it
before folks
and it worked it worked
we did not have the type of mass
shootings that we have today
that we've had since 2004.
why is that date significant hmm i
wonder why
so let's stop the head-up bass syndrome
here because that's all this
[ __ ] is his head up ass syndrome [ __ ]
gaslighting
it's fear-mongering it's all [ __ ]
every last [ __ ] bit of it and we
always fall for this mental illness one
[ __ ] them we are not going to fall for
this sure
we can fix mental illness in this
country let's pass universal health care
universal background checks and
universal ban on assault weapons
there you go we can do it all at once
and we can
sign it all up right away and all the
men all the people blaming on mental
illness should be lined up to sign that
goddamn thing
they won't and the reason why is because
the
the people that are mentally ill in this
country the ones that are sick
that are deluded believing this garbage
these [ __ ]
stupid lies and these stupid arguments
about about
guns and assault weapons
these aren't the people that are lying
to them
the politicians are lying to them and
when i mean the politicians are lying to
them
i mean republicans that's what i mean
republicans are [ __ ] lying to you
they're lying to you no one's coming to
get your guns
you do not have to buy up all the ammo
there will be ammo to have after this
you will be able to buy ammo you'll be
able to buy ammo
for the guns that you still have that
you will be able to buy
that you will be able to purchase now
rather it's a little difficult to go
purchase those things or not well that
might be the question
i mean again for someone for someone who
[ __ ] tries to get a license to cut
hair in most states they have to [ __ ]
go get a background check
they have to get a license teachers
teachers
if you're a teacher if you're a [ __ ]
teacher
in most states you have to get a license
you have to get a background check and
you even have to put your little [ __ ]
fingerprint
you have to get fingerprinted if you're
gonna be a teacher
to be a teacher okay do you understand
boneheads do you get it to get a [ __ ]
license
you gotta go take a test a driver's
license you gotta go take a test
you fill a little form with all your
information your address your social
security number your date of birth
you give them all of that you give it
all to them
and you take a test and then they test
you to make sure you test
make sure you know how to drive and then
you have to renew that [ __ ]
and then when you go get your car if you
buy an automobile to drive your own
automobile
as opposed to renting or borrowing one
you gotta get it licensed
sometimes you gotta get it inspected
it's gotta pass an
inspection in some states then you gotta
run on down to the government office
that tyrannical government office
and license it and i and
let's let's put it in a little better
terms you know all those big
stupid trucks with all the trump flags
on the back of them
every single one of those trucks has
walked
on down to the tyrannical government's
office to license those [ __ ]
they license them and i guarantee you
almost every single one of them has a
goddamn mortgage against it at a bank
so the end so the bank requires them to
have an insurance policy so then they
gotta
they go to the fdic bank which is
insured by the federal government that
tyrannical government that you talk
about
then they run on down to the insurance
office to buy a policy that's regulated
by
the tyrannical government and they sign
up for an insurance policy for their
[ __ ]
little dick truck because they got a
dick complex
not only do they got a dick complex with
their big tires and their jacked up
truck they got to have a
40-foot flag on it that says trump 2020
and their confederate flag because you
know america
every single one of those that you see
every [ __ ] one of them
heavily heavily regulated heavily
licensed and heavily insured
but the guns inside the truck the guns
inside the truck
maybe not so [ __ ] much
well i think i've been on my soapbox
long enough today
we didn't make it to quite an hour but
we made it pretty goddamn close
and i'm excited that you guys join me
and come back next week
because next week wednesday at three
o'clock we're gonna be right here
and hopefully next week we do not have
to talk about another mass shooting in
this country
i hope i do not have to continue this
[ __ ] conversation
again and again and again and again
but it's long as long as we have some of
these politicians
that get their pockets full with the gun
lobby and the gun manufacturers
we will continue to have policy in this
country that is going to fill the
pockets
of the gun manufacturers and use
fear-mongering to do it
you can guarantee that so i guess the
lesson here
is two things number one we need to
become one issue voters in this country
and the one issue we need to concentrate
on is end
the filibuster end it now
end that [ __ ] archaic stupid
process
which yes mitch mcconnell it does have
it does have a racial history
in that [ __ ] now
now and vote vote
vote vote vote go [ __ ]
vote there is 81 million people in this
country
that voted against this trumpism [ __ ]
it's enough go vote do not let up
do not let up and keep voting you hear
me georgia
you hear me texas you hear me missouri
you hear me iowa you hear me arizona
what about
michigan wisconsin minnesota i'm talking
to you too
hey ohio there's gonna be a seat
go vote vote
vote vote like your life depends on it
because it [ __ ] very well
may depend on it
[ __ ] them you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime
follow tony on social media at the tony
michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after me
[ __ ] them